the Russian calm and snikt the archer
samanya anyone you know agree now nor
the odd Walter Queen the green arrow
being Russia the same time
very good if Oliver Queen is a green
hair
and now mr. stark has prepared a
statement he will not be taking any
questions thank you in a while mm front
of you I figure I'll stick your cards
this time there's been speculation that
I was involved in the events that
occurred the freeway and the rooftops
I'm sorry to start with you honestly
expect us to believe that that was a
bodyguard in a suit that conveniently
appeared despite the fact that I know
that it's confusing it is one thing to
question the official story and another
thing entirely to make wild accusations
or insinuate that I'm a superhero
I never said you're a superhero didn't
well good because that would be
outlandish and fantastic I'm just not
the hero type clearly with this laundry
list of character defects all the
mistakes I've made largely public yes
truth is
I am Iron Man
see youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my arrow episode 12 episode 13
trailer video just careful for spoilers
from episode 12 if you haven't seen it
yet there's a big Iron Man reveal moment
that they teased at the end of the
episode Oliver's going to have to have
his moment where he just comes out in
public and says I'm the green arrow so
just keep your eyes peeled on the
horizon for something like that that
seems to be what they're foreshadowing
but there's a new round of the flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video what I'm going to
do because the schedule for all the TV
shows is a little different next week
I'll explain that at the end of this but
to deal with the trailer for the next
episode is sort of a follow up on the
idea of wild dogs backstory the idea
he's so gun crazy in the vigilante
character so it's going to be one of
those situations where Oliver can't
solve a problem as Green Arrow he has to
do it as mayor Queen just more
foreshadowing that the two identities
will become one identity eventually
people will know him as both Oliver
Queen and the Green Arrow not just his
friends what's your administration's
position on gun control that is
complicated if the bad guys got guns
y'all scrapping up too we cannot dismiss
the idea that we're just beating into a
vicious cycle find representation I
asked before it does weaken
this is a problem to clean out Kenneth's
assault so top time WTF comic book
Easter eggs number ten more Talia and
Oliver training she's trying to teach
him that going dark is actually good for
him it gives you better sight you see
more clearly walking in darkness so
she's trying to get him to become the
green arrow or the hood because that's
what he was called in season one the
thing with this is that this is all
building towards him going back to
Starling city remember it was still
called Starling city in the first season
but he hasn't faced Kovar yet that's
coming up in the flashbacks in a future
episode
so Dolph Lundgren will be coming back to
the show relatively soon he is still the
big boss of the flashbacks number nine
is Oliver and Susan in present day
finally getting it on he's moving
forward in all aspects of his life but
the funny thing about this is that it's
all very tongue-in-cheek because she's
trying to get information on him there's
still the Prometheus stuff going on in
the background and all this stuff got
dredged up from his past that will
probably become another problem for him
in the future with the Bratva so number
seven
another problem comes back Quentin is
back from rehab more quips more awkward
humor more lashing out at the thought of
what happened to Laurel what he did last
year all his mistakes getting into bed
with damian darhk-- so wild dog tries to
help about they had a lot of great
scenes together but it seems like this
is who his character is going to be for
the rest of the season they kind of did
that on the flash like Caitlin's
character was kramat eyes by a zoom she
changed going forward even with all the
flashpoint changes all the characters
are suffering from something in dealing
with it in different ways cisco lost his
brother so that kind of thing is going
on with Quentin's character eventually
he'll find a way to move past it but he
was never that happy of a character to
begin with he spent the first couple of
seasons trying to catch the arrow and
take him down
but number six they had this really
awesome wild dog story about how Quentin
helped him it becomes it's really
positive thing but I was a little kid
tagging building you gave me this great
speech but then sort of a lead-in to the
next episode like the trailer footage
the way of the gun he asked them how did
you end up getting dishonorably dish
from the military if I set you on the
good path he's like nobody's perfect so
if you don't remember the story of how
wild dog got discharged from the
military he was on board a ship they
were interrogating a prisoner and things
were getting out of hand
wild dog shut it down disobeying a
direct order from a superior officer and
it led to him being dishonorably
discharged so he did something bad for
the right reasons because he's a good
person that's the whole idea like
they're good people but they crossed the
line big time so next when I should
think I messed the numbers up so at
number six
félicité goes super hardcore with the
pandora data so this is going to get her
into some really big trouble later on in
the season they just tease the idea that
she's crossing into morally gray area
threatening people in a way that you
wouldn't normally see her do so she
believes she's doing the right thing
seeking out justice taking down bad
people using methods that are outside of
the law
so eventually there'll be a reckoning
she'll have to deal with that I don't
think she's going to go to prison or
anything like that but she might have to
go on the run for a brief period she is
definitely going to get in some big
trouble eventually even though the way
to hell is paved with good intentions
she's going to have some big takedowns
but it's going to come at great cost
number five was the general escaping
captivity causing team arrow to road
trip to Russia it's been a long time I
think it was season two was the last
actual russia road trip episode and he
gets punched right in the face by KGB's
the minute he shows up it was great
number four I totally love all the KGB
scenes he's so awesome
David nickel you may remember him from
Stargate all of his arrow stuff has been
great from all the previous seasons it's
always fun to see him back so the whole
deal here is that Oliver in the
flashbacks is slowly coming to the point
where he has to leave the Bratva so that
he can go back to Starling city
but KGB's keeps telling him that you
don't leave that kind of oats behind so
through the course of the episode he
sort of re-ups
with the Bratva unofficially meaning the
KGB's will come visit him eventually in
Star City you're the boss now
it'll be fun we'll have a good time when
I come visit so that is going to be a
really big problem for him because it's
the Mayoress scene working with the
Bratva
people are going to have a lot of
questions for
Porter's like Susan Williams are going
to have a lot of questions so just
remember that for the future number
three was Diggle almost killing that
guard trying to get intel I totally love
it when Diggle Hulk's out and crosses
the line like I actually thought that he
killed that guy till none of the other
characters said that out loud I feel
like if he had killed him then they
would have acknowledged that but in the
way that all of her speech that he got
from the Black Canary he passes on to
the other people about how they make
each other better people they influence
each other's lives that sort of the
thing that prometheus is throwing in his
face yeah you influence the people
around you but that's a good thing so
Black Canary gave him the speech that he
gave to everyone else
the Diggle repeats at the end where he
has that OGT marrow speech where he's
talking to felicity you know you me
Oliver we make each other better so it
ends up being a good thing by the end of
the episode number two was a Ragman
stopping the nuke
sacrificing his powers so a lot of you
seem bummed that he's going to be off
the show he'll totally come back the
whole idea is that you don't need the
superpowers to be a superhero so either
he's going to recharge the rags or he's
going to come back and be a badass
without them which the second option
seems more likely just based on the way
the seasons going like everyone has
something to offer even if you're not a
superhero but it was a super bummer to
see him sacrifice those like he was one
of the coolest characters the way his
power worked the way he just drops in
and fights
but the big number one WTF is Susan
Williams pretty much figuring out that
Oliver is the green arrow she doesn't
say it outright she says it's like the
biggest coincidence ever but she pretty
much implies that she's going to out him
eventually that's where we're headed
so that is why Oliver is probably going
to be forced with a very Iron Man type
situation at the end of that movie where
everyone's questioning Tony Stark after
that big fight with the Iron Monger
questioning him who is Iron Man what's
going on what is your relationship with
them and he just throws the cards down
on the table and says you know what I am
Iron Man
so that he becomes both of those
personas embodied in one person it's no
longer one or the other it's the same
person no matter who you're talking to
so it'll be really interesting to see if
that happens going into season six what
that change is about his relationship
with the city itself because there's
only one of two ways I could go one
mayor Oliver Queen stops being mayor
Oliver Queen or two everyone embraces
the idea and it becomes super comic book
II pulling even more weirdos out of the
woodwork so it was a great episode let
me know what you guys favorite moment
was all explains a video scheduled in
next week because there are two shows I
was actually wrong I thought that all
the DC shows were going on break but
Supergirl
and arrow are still new only flash in
legends of tomorrow or on break so I'll
be posting bonus videos for DC TV stuff
like flash next week I'll just remind
people when I post that but it was a
great episode I always loved the road
trips Black Canary you see they're
playing with her powers just a little
bit the way her sonic cry works
it was fun to see her flip a truck and
even though people will still be upset
about all the Black Canary stuff going
on behind the scenes I feel like the
show is better with a black Canary
regardless of how it went down for those
of you asking about prometheus stuff
they'll be coming back around to that
there'll be another big Prometheus
episode really soon just like there'll
be another big savitur episode of the
flash really soon so we're heading into
what they technically call sweeps week
that's when all the crazy stuff really
happens Stephen Amell was teasing that a
lot of big stuff is all going to be
happening all at the same time on arrow
and all the other shows too for that
matter so it's going to be crazy the
next couple weeks
gratulations to the new flash ring
giveaway winner ninja ned 99 please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details what's going to happen next is I
have new spider-man homecoming Ironman
he's got a new suit during spider-man
homecoming so I'll do a video for that
so that'll post Friday morning is going
to be awesome
while you wait for that you can click
here for my Legion episode 1 video and
you can click here for the trailer for
the next episode of the flash thank you
so much for watching everyone so set bot
I'll see you guys in the next video
you